I know in the beginning kind of seemed
like a lot of poop jokes but it really
gets deep it's a lot deeper than poop
was contaminated become a breakout star
on American band I mean everybody is
tweeting about you talking about you and
you're one of my favorites this season
because you showed so much range I mean
you went from you know this jock that
kind of egotistical and you were
charming in some areas and then you got
emotional talk to me about just like
what it took to show that kind of range
and how that was for you as an actor I
feel like that whole image of like a
star athlete you kind of just see him is
like he's just athlete he's a gladiator
he's you know toughest stone and that's
just it but behind that a lot of times
is insecurities you know you feel lonely
at time just like anybody else you know
person I mean it was like an onion you
were just pulling back layers with him
so I instantly thought I'm like are you
like this in real life like how much
does art imitate life when it comes to
DeMarcus Tillman and Melvin Greg when it
comes to myself I guess the the main
similarity was just I guess the
loneliness that came with the popularity
knowing so many people know you a lot of
times it's like your world gets a lot
smaller yeah so I could definitely
relate to that coming from a social
media world where you know your whole
life is kind of just put out my street
the reaction that you've gotten from
DeMarcus Tillman are there any crazy
themes have you had any wild fan
encounters like what's like Vincent's
taking on this role reckon vendo help me
reach a different demo so it's cool to
see those people come up and you know
Rover flake like guys I'm gonna expect
like people to drive a dump truck and
like this the mailman that one oh yeah I
guess because it whole I get all work I
won't want to see none of that size that
what if the mole
just poop is funny talk to me about
another scene that was really graphic or
it was blurred did you have to send in
some leaked photo it won't leak device
in them now basically there was like yo
we need these type of pictures we could
see this that in other two recreated
pictures I'm like nah it's cool I got it
I got it
I've been shooting videos for like five
six years so I have a production studio
and I have like a room full of just
props and costumes so I kind of has
something there that I was able to you
know make a look so but the thing is it
was funny I sent this one because they
were just asking for and it's real was
just like Melvin we need like this nude
so people on the threated then really
know the nature what we was talking
about as I was going on so when I send a
picture that it just looked really real
I took it so I look real it's like wait
what was going on what are you doing Oh
Melvin so graphic we just need the seven
other and then I send the actual picture
like where you see the thing detached
from my body in my head but have you
ever been catfished though this is over
ten years ago it was just Twitter it was
a guy was talking to on Twitter you know
just saying look slick witty stuff and
we exchanged numbers
and then I was called it I like try to
FaceTime him and the cow going black oh
yeah this is clearance on and then on
her thing she was like she was she was
supposed to be like this Cuban girl who
lived over there but I'll let it start
within one time I'll call and I heard a
voice in the back before they hung up
and it definitely didn't sound right I
kind of just jumped out not it was like
probably not Cuban okay okay Rondo you
know Cuban people don't have a specific
sound but I was already curious I was
like and I don't sound like another
flight so I just there's enough women in
real life that that you can talk to
people
I mean I love the school a lot of people
and people love me I feel like I'm
friends with everybody
do you think the Marcus has an arc that
can cross over into season three I mean
you could definitely go further with the
story she goes to college and all but
just what this show is it goes to a
different world and it just explored
this was different topics so yeah I feel
like it'll probably go somewhere
completely different than then this past
season and it'll be just as exciting
right do you think maybe in future
seasons though DeMarcus could come and
how would you want him to come if you
had you know you were in the writers
room right right uh maybe I mean
DeMarcus
being an athlete that he is you probably
go to college for a year then probably
go to the NBA so I could probably have a
lot of fun with that and gay players
they uh big on pranks - especially with
rookies coming in so probably find
something that will squeeze you look
real different right but it's still my
man it don't matter like I'm no more
importance to this teen and the rest of
these guys if you know on my score 31
it's where we balance this nasty there's
a lot of buzz going on right now since
your role in American band know people
are saying that you need an Emmy
nomination how would you react to
something like that I think that the
coolest part about gonna end me for the
markets tell me was would be it will be
for a character like that to get and
because I don't really see too many
characters like that on TV especially in
the world that that American vandal is
like it's not really an urban centric
type show and but that character is but
he's still true to the situation in the
world around him is still true to a lot
of stuff I see on TV it's kind of like
it's composed the relationships are
composing on releasing seeing will
there's like they're scripted to like
each other opposed to it yeah this
character is truly years this characters
truly is and they really have a
relationship and I feel like we were
able to do that on American vendor
fighters were great and you know all the
actors and like I said a great
collaborative environment
[Music]